Trascrizione: Ale Unam
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Dunque, iniziamo facendo
un breve salto nel futuro:
non un futuro qualsiasi,
ma il futuro immaginato dal film
"Ready Player One" di Steven Spielberg,
qualcuno l'avrà visto.
Un futuro distopico, tanto per cambiare.
Perché distopico?
Perché in questo 2045,
a causa di una crisi energetica,
le persone stanno male
e allora si rifugiano
in un mondo virtuale,
dove hanno la maggior parte
delle loro relazioni,
dove fanno la maggior parte
delle loro cose.
Quindi smettono di vivere nel mondo reale
e iniziano a vivere
in questo mondo virtuale.
Adesso torniamo al 2021,
cioè torniamo al presente;
un pochino è diventato
un brutto posto anche il presente,
soprattutto nell'ultimo anno,
a causa della pandemia.
E allora,
la maggior parte delle nostre relazioni
si sono svolte nella sfera del virtuale.
Ora un po' meno, speriamo
che continui a migliorare;
però sappiamo tutti
di quello che sto parlando.
Ovviamente parlo di una sfera del virtuale
che è molto diversa da quella
che abbiamo visto nel film di Spielberg,
anzi non parliamo neanche di virtuale;
la parola che usiamo è distanza.
Lavoro a distanza, scuola a distanza;
certo, siamo tutti ben contenti
che le tecnologie ci abbiano permesso
di fare tutta una serie
di cose a distanza.
Basterebbe solo immaginarsi
cosa sarebbe stata una pandemia
20 o 30 anni fa, senza Internet.
Però, dopo un anno e mezzo,
la presenza ci comincia a mancare.
Siamo tutti ben contenti
di fare un po' di cose in presenza;
i più contenti di tutti
sono le persone che hanno
a che fare con la scuola.
Questo è un grafico di un'indagine
che è stata fatta
dal mio istituto, INDIRE,
che mostra la qualità percepita
della didattica a distanza
da parte degli insegnanti.
Non c'è da capire
cosa sono tutte quelle barrette:
ci basta vedere in che verso vanno,
cioè verso il basso.
Quasi tutte le dimensioni
dell'apprendimento
sono peggiorate
nella didattica a distanza,
nell'opinione dei docenti, tranne una;
quella verde, che va in su,
e che è l'autonomia
e la responsabilità degli studenti:
quella è migliorata.
Tutto il resto è peggiorato,
e non di poco.
Quindi, l'opinione comune
è che la didattica debba essere
fatta in un luogo fisico,
perché la didattica in un luogo fisico,
la didattica in presenza,
è migliore di quella a distanza;
e non solo la didattica.
Perché quante volte sentiamo dire:
"I ragazzi stanno troppo su internet.
bisognerebbe che uscissero di più,
perché si dedicassero, in questo modo,
alle relazioni vere".
E qui bisogna chiedersi: come mai
le relazioni a distanza sono meno vere?
Anzi, cosa si intende per relazioni vere?
Forse si vuole dire
che la presenza è forse
il medium più potente che c'è,
e che tutto il resto è,
e continuerà a essere,
una versione degradata
delle relazioni in presenza.
Ora, per rispondere a queste domande
io vorrei tornare un attimino nel futuro,
in quel 2045 descritto
dal film "Ready Player One";
però questa volta non il film,
ma il libro da cui il film è stato tratto.
Perché nel libro c'è un capitolo
che descrive una normale
mattinata in classe,
di un adolescente che va a scuola.
E allora questo adolescente
indossa dei visori,
si immerge in una realtà virtuale
in cui ci sono i suoi compagni di classe
e l'insegnante che spiega;
solo che ad un certo punto
li teletrasporta a visitare
la tomba di Tutankhamon
e poi su Marte, ad analizzare
il suolo marziano.
Ora capite bene che queste sono cose
che in presenza non si possono fare.
E allora, forse varrebbe la pena
non solo paragonare la distanza
a quello che si può fare in presenza,
perché questo ci porta
a considerarla, sempre e comunque,
il parente povero della presenza;
ma pensare a qual è
il valore aggiunto della distanza,
le cose che a distanza
si possono fare, e in presenza no.
Ora magari qualcuno si starà chiedendo:
ma queste cose che ci hai fatto vedere
sono così state fatte al computer,
oppure già esistono?
Ma in realtà esistono già,
cioè le cose che abbiamo visto
in questo ultimo video
sono tecnologie che esistono
già al giorno d'oggi.
La prima parte di quel video
è una tecnologia sviluppata da H-Farm,
una piattaforma di innovazione
che risiede a 20 chilometri da qui,
da dove ci troviamo adesso.
Però, facciamo degli esempi
anche meno futuristici:
in realtà, delle scuole a distanza
esistono già da qualche anno.
Eccone una, per esempio:
si tratta di un'università
in cui i corsi si frequentano da remoto.
Sono corsi che non esisterebbero
nella tua città;
anzi, in molti casi
non esistono neppure in Italia.
Quindi se uno li volesse
frequentare in presenza
dovrebbe trasferirsi all'estero:
che non è una brutta cosa,
però se hai mezzi economici per farlo,
perché altrimenti le cose
si complicano un bel po'.
E allora, poter frequentare
un corso a distanza
significa poter frequentare
delle università, e non solo,
che altrimenti non potresti frequentare.
E qui ci sono tutta una serie di categorie
che non potrebbero frequentare altrimenti.
Pensiamo a un adulto che ha una famiglia,
che ha un lavoro a tempo pieno
e che non potrebbe frequentare
una scuola in presenza,
perché ha bisogno di una
flessibilità di tempi e di modi
che la scuola in presenza
difficilmente può dare.
Facciamo anche degli altri esempi;
perché ad esempio, non so se lo sapete,
ma in Italia e non solo
ci sono una serie di piccoli
centri abitati, semi isolati -
pensiamo alle piccole isole,
o anche a dei centri montani;
ecco, questo è un esempio.
Cosa sta succedendo,
da qualche anno a questa parte?
Che diventa difficile fare scuola
in questi piccoli centri,
perché non ci sono abbastanza studenti.
E allora la scuola va in crisi,
le famiglie si spostano;
e il motivo, la causa
è soprattutto la scuola,
perché vanno dove la scuola c'è.
Negli ultimi anni, i governi
che si sono succeduti
hanno investito tanto sul ripopolamento
di questi piccoli centri;
e questo passa soprattutto dalla scuola,
perché è chiaro che se un bambino
non riesce a fare scuola
difficilmente potrà vivere
in questi piccoli centri.
Ecco allora che una scuola
a distanza, credibile,
in cui in qualche modo si riesce
con efficacia a fare didattica
diventa una possibilità
per alcune famiglie
di rimanere in questi centri,
per altre addirittura
di andarci ad abitare.
Ecco, siamo arrivati un po'
al concetto di democrazia;
in questo caso si sta parlando
di alcune forme di didattica a distanza
che in determinati contesti
sono più democratici
della didattica in presenza,
per i motivi che vi ho appena detto.
Certo, qualcuno starà pensando:
va bene, ma qui si parla
solo di didattica,
e la scuola non ha mica
solo questa funzione, quella didattica;
c'è ad esempio la funzione
di socializzazione secondaria.
Quella primaria è quella
dei primi anni di vita,
che avviene in famiglia;
poi dopo c'è una
socializzazione secondaria
che è affidata soprattutto alla scuola,
perché è lì che si cominciano
a fare nuove amicizie,
e si allarga la rete sociale.
E la scuola ha anche questa funzione,
e la relazione passa attraverso
tutta una serie di canali di comunicazione
che ancora, per lo meno ancora,
non sono stati sviluppati a distanza.
E poi c'è una terza
funzione importante della scuola,
ce ne siamo accorti
soprattutto in questo ultimo anno.
E cioè, la custodia dei minori.
Perché la scuola è quella cosa
che permette - che si prende
la responsabilità dei minori,
e permette ai genitori
che entrambi lavorano
di poter disporre
del loro tempo lavorativo,
perché in quel momento
la responsabilità dei figli
è affidata ad altri.
Quindi tre funzioni importanti,
che sono racchiuse in uno stesso tempo
e in uno stesso edificio,
il tempo scuola e l'edificio scuola.
Forse bisognerebbe pensare
ad una relazione, a un modello
un pochino più flessibile
dove queste tre funzioni
non sono per forza racchiuse
in uno stesso tempo
e in uno stesso spazio,
che è quello dell'edificio scuola.
Però chiaramente questo è un modello
che deve essere ancora sviluppato,
e che in qualche modo pone
dei problemi importanti.
Qui c'è un altro problema,
della didattica a distanza.
Perché una delle obiezioni più grandi
che gli viene fatta
è che non è democratica;
non è democratica perché
bisogna investire in tecnologia,
bisogna avere le tecnologie.
E allora, il rischio
è quello che le famiglie ricche,
gli studenti ricchi,
abbiano le tecnologie migliori:;
e che questo gli consenta
un accesso migliore
rispetto alle altre famiglie,
quindi una disparità.
Vero, però vorrei farvi una domanda:
voi lo sapete quanto spende una famiglia
per un figlio che studia,
dal primo all'ultimo anno di scuola,
l'ultimo anno della secondaria?
Eccolo qua: più o meno
140 - 240 euro all'anno,
ma poi alle superiori la cifra aumenta.
Ho fatto io un po' il totale:
si va dai 2100 ai 3100 euro
della carriera scolastica del figlio.
Ci sono delle scuole che hanno deciso
di abbattere questi costi;
lo avrete capito no,
si sta parlando di costi
per l'acquisto di libri di testo.
Queste scuole, una in particolare -
o meglio, una rete
di scuole in particolare,
la rete "Book in Progress",
fatta di 300 scuole in tutt'Italia
che hanno deciso di prodursi in casa,
o meglio a scuola, i libri di testo.
Sono gli insegnanti che scrivono i libri,
e poi li distribuiscono
agli studenti della scuola.
E fanno un patto con le famiglie:
i soldi che risparmi
per l'acquisto dei libri di testo
li puoi investire, e ti chiediamo
di investirli in tecnologia.
Ad esempio per l'acquisto di tablet,
che permetteranno poi
di fruire di quei testi
che sono stati prodotti dagli insegnanti.
Facciamo anche un altro esempio.
Allora, voi conoscete
Spotify, Netflix, eccetera eccetera;
sono piattaforme di streaming
o comunque di accesso ai contenuti:
non di acquisto,
dei contenuti, ma di accesso.
Si paga un tot al mese
per accedere a dei contenuti,
a tutti i contenuti o perlomeno a tanti.
Ecco, voi provate a immaginare
se gli editori scolastici
si mettessero d'accordo
su un modello commerciale
che prevede un accesso per ogni studente
a una cifra che potrebbe essere
verosimilmente questa;
non ad alcuni libri di testo,
i cosiddetti libri in adozione -
voi lo sapete:
l'insegnante adotta un testo,
ed è quello che gli studenti acquistano -
non solo a quei libri,
non solo ad un libro
di matematica e di fisica,
ma a tutti o a gran parte dei libri.
Questo vorrebbe dire ristrutturare un po'
l'accesso alla conoscenza scolastica;
poter studiare su una quantità
di fonti molto più ampia.
Diciamo che, arrivati a questo punto,
mi sto chiedendo se noi,
soprattutto in questo ultimo anno,
ci siamo fatti la domanda sbagliata.
Perché la domanda che si è sentita
nei giornali, telegiornali, dibattiti, è:
quanto la scuola a distanza,
la didattica a distanza,
riuscisse a essere all'altezza
di quella in presenza.
Quanto non riesce a fare?
Quanto fa male?
Quanto non sta facendo
la didattica a distanza?
Forse bisognerebbe ribaltare la domanda,
forse la domanda vera
da chiedersi è questa:
cosa è che la scuola
in presenza non sta facendo,
o sta facendo poco o sta facendo male?
Ecco: se fosse questa la domanda,
allora forse scopriremmo che la scuola
così come l'abbiamo sempre conosciuta
non è la scuola migliore,
non è la scuola più democratica.
E allora scopriremmo, anche,
che forse la distanza, nei prossimi anni,
potrà essere uno dei nostri
migliori alleati.
Grazie.
(Applausi)